you know this story coming out of Brazil
how do you keep something like that tied
down so well you would you know you
really don't think about I think what I
mean when I first heard it was kind of
ridiculous when did you first hear about
it two days ago two days two days ago
that's when they're saying it happened
it happened the day actually so three
days probably most three days ago but
it's sometimes I think it happened last
Wednesday right yeah exactly
and so you know when I called up the
guys to ask him that question it wasn't
what am i a me I got something really
cool to ask you about a gun or about
some sort of thermal imager and night
vision or you know whatever it was about
UFOs and I could hear the guys kind of
chuckling in the back so it's funny you
know you when you don't really take into
consideration that it's real I mean
listen I have when you talk to people
who see Bigfoot I mean dude these are
people who not only tell you a story but
look have fear in their eyes yeah I
talked to a cat here in Florida who was
up in the Panhandle in a little area
called Torreya State Park it's probably
one of the coolest parks in the state
you know it's like going to the North
Carolina but you only have to go five
hours to get there and got little
streams and running water and you know
80-foot Bluffs and great hiking trails
just a beautiful place yeah and he saw
an 8-foot actually recorded it with a
thermal imager and took a video of it as
a step between two trees one of these
Bigfoot organizations got ahold of the
information that's how I ended up seeing
on YouTube and went back and looked at
the same tree where this guy was said
this animal was and when this animal was
standing behind the tree one of the
first things you didn't notice is you
can see his shoulders on each side of
the tree when they put this guy that was
six foot four in front of the tree you
could only see his shoulder if he popped
one side out on one side of the tree or
the other mm-hmm when he took these
steps out to walk away it took about two
steps for this animal to be completely
out of the picture and it took him like
five steps to get out of the picture
so you know listening to things being it
was huge he's that was over eight feet
you know we start charcoal and listen I
used to go camping out there and
backpack on and I've never seen anything
yet he's got on video
not like that this guy was scared he was
telling the story I'm not going back out
there again I know there's animals out
there now that yeah you know are much
bigger than me and I'm not you know he
was about a shot this thing I just made
a mad yeah so you know again you look at
the kind of individual where do these
stories come from or listen are we
headed for some new point and man's
existence now that something's gonna be
revealed to us you guys locked down all
these weird things are going on around
them on the planet
um what's really going on yeah you know
you look at the pandemic when you start
talking about how we ended up where
we're at here today this brazilian thing
oh and did I tell you to by the way this
is kind of odd president Trump put on a
travel ban today to Brazil so really so
is that weird I mean again so is it just
is it a coincidence it's kind of one of
those weird moments that you're like wow
dude
check this out it all it does is be in
the fire right you know and the people
who are diehards are you know know me
tell you this is why right AP Associated
Press White House imposes coronavirus
travel ban to Brazil on Brazil which is
crazy Wow
and again you know again is that a weird
set of circumstances cuz listen
everybody that's in the video that's
talking about this thing the crash dears
wearing a mask yeah so you know there's
there's some legitimacy there but again
what why preserve all the sides why did
they get picked up that's freaky of all
the places right now with that coming up
and it's funny they just now decided to
do that literally 12 hours ago I think
cuz if you look at the when the message
came out was 12 or 13 hours ago so three
days after this supposed UFO crashed in
Brazil the US decides to put a travel
ban you're not going so again it's just
now that raises my blood pressure just a
little bit but see it's so little events
like that that take place that you'll
make you go wait a minute really yeah
come on man I didn't listen when I first
got go all the way back to the first guy
that asked me the question he did
something crash in Brazil no dude who
crashes in Brazil I mean come on
they're aerospace program do the Alvin
aerospace program no they don't
why would anybody be interested in what
they do right so like I say when I first
came to me I kind of joked about it then
well the other guy
called me up and asked me and he wasn't
doing it from a hey man and who is the
other guy just my buddy over at the
State Department at the State Department
yes his name is Terri Brandis okay I can
say his name's not a big deal okay he's
not a spook doesn't anything important
super nice guy but just interested and
this is as I am yeah
from Oh from oh hey Wow check this out
and so he called me up with it and
because this guy's had a little bit more
of a background and he's you know again
start telling me I just I'm asking
because some I heard some hoopla about
it yeah like well you're at the State
Department who cares about right well I
mean listen if it's a real UFO we have a
lot to say about it so start this peel
the layers of the onion back okay let me
just ask somebody call my buddies up you
know we're having a listen these guys
aren't pre-tested we've never even had a
UFO conversation with him about this
okay so it's not part of again who we
are we're all dealing in weapon
platforms and guns and explosives and
yeah that's very very cool and you know
we all love that these guys were all
knuckle draggers they're the some of the
best warriors in the world this was the
last thing that anyway thought was gonna
call him ask him about which kind of
brings more validity to the story
because then he goes back and he just
doesn't ask his team within Gaara he
goes back to BOPE and not only this boat
know about it they got a perimeter set
up around this place nothing's locked
down wait a minute and BOPE is
communicating back to him basically just
admitting to him yeah a UFO landed he's
one of them he was a commander within
Gaara so these guys it's like everything
else listen if you were if you're part
of the end if you're part of the know
and you're part of the no I don't mind
sharing tactics with you on how to
assault an airplane if I know we're on
the same team if we're not on the same
team um you're never gonna know I know I
even know I know how to an assault a
plane yeah so this is kind of that same
format dealing with guys who are
like-minded again these guys these guys
did it for 25 one guy was 25 years here
the guy was 29 years hmm with Gaara so
they know all the top guys with BOPE and
Bhopal these guys it's you know when
they went there just to give an example
and to make you understand what civil
rights are all about I had trained a
bunch of them here on it so it's called
a 40 mike-mike they're these little um
they shoot wooden batons and they're
basically for crowd control and so there
I'm showing there's about a hundred guys
here I'm instructing they're gonna go
back and show ninety-eight thousand guys
how to use these Wow
so and they're getting ready to have the
what's the big soccer game they have
every year the World Cup was taking
place in Brazil and they were getting
ready to train all the guys up so they
came over here anyways [ __ ] get crazy
during the world caller do they get real
crazy well they were mad too because
they were spending all this money on the
World Cup and the people believe that
money goes to us she'd be coming back
here to the States and not being used
for this World Cup event that's came
back we've put all these millions and
millions of dollars out of here so they
were mad and what they do is they set up
three rings of security to make sure
they keep the tourists that are there to
see the games safe and so they go
through this whole process get it set up
well I'm showing these guys how to use
these the wooden batons and what you're
supposed to do is kind of shoot the
ground and you skip them off the hitch
across the shins and they make you
change your mind of wanting to riot and
hey well what they would do was they
would actually shoot the guys like in
the ribs and on the face [ __ ] and kill
him and drag their bodies off and I'm
like dude what are you doing he's like
aids this is not America you don't have
civil rights here we tell you to get out
of here you don't get out of here
whatever happens you happens to you and
you're on your own
so and that's the way it goes so gara is
that first group and then BOPE is above
them with regards to if it Bob's coming
to get you if Bob rolls in it's gonna be
a bad day they're not there to talk
anybody out of the building they're
probably gonna level the building with
you in it so you know again taking into
consideration that's really what we
talked about dude these guys were blown
away the fact how do you know in the
u.s. that we've got an event taking
place here and books and we don't know
that no I said listen I got lucky
because it was just a kind of a queer
coincidence of how we ended up here yeah
but for you guys to confirm it I said
has anybody released any information
because week I'm not finding anymore
other than hey man we got something here
it went down the night before you have a
security a perimeter set up you know I'm
sure that I mean the first thing I would
think about is radioactivity so I'm
always I don't want to run into any
place that's gonna be you know hot and
be like how did Hanks Dimmick dying yeah
so but again it's to me it's one of
these events that take place that can't
be ignored
you think we'll hear more news about it
or I would say we would almost have to
it's somebody is gonna pull the plug on
this and want to be the first guy to
talk about it this is the video right
there so is this the right video this is
this is the video of the lights over
Brazil the lights
apparently the crash right yeah like I
see there's several different ones
there's a bunch of different I think I
sent you that actually sent them to your
phone yeah you did and all right now
this looks like this is the video that's
in embedded in a vice article okay now
see that the yellow one shows these red
lights there's it's just variable I told
you looks like a movie yeah it's really
it's really strange with regards to the
actual yeah the thing is I don't know if
you can just trust some random meme page
on Instagram I'll pull up that video
real quick well and listen I think to
and I forgot to you can bring up do you
member that day this is the video you
sent me right here there it is right
there that's the one right there
now I haven't seen this video anywhere
else now the police are going crazy you
can see everything that's going on
there's I knows no sound on this is
sideline culture on Instagram so again
even if you say okay that's not a UFO
alright fine what are you looking at
what is this what are those lights on
the sky are those drones so this looks
similar to what was on the Vice article
this part right here that first thing
with that thinks that big like hula hoop
looking thing I haven't seen that
anywhere else no I mean even looks like
I say this is obviously this is
definitely in in Brazil I mean there
speaking Portuguese yeah I don't
understand what they're saying I
actually probably need to go down and
talk to the guys that are here and what
are they saying are they saying look at
that thing in the sky
look at that thing in the sky yeah the
other one I had actually shows him
watching rockets off and the Rockets are
going off yeah you can hear lotions
going off well there's a defensive
defensive measure but you're like well
what are the Brazilians who their war
with what are they shooting these things
off for so that's it this is the clip
that shows the part of the map that's
whited out or cut out and it like I say
it's compelling it's just very
compelling and you know you start
looking again you take these little
events here take that event there and
all of a sudden they end up somewhere
like this and can you imagine what'll
happen if there's actually a vehicle
here that's crashed and they come out to
the world say hey listen you actually
got it and oh by the way here's the
bodies you think they would actually do
that I don't think so no I don't think
so but at the same token you know you
kind of get caught with your pants down
hey what are you doing there with your
pants down yeah well I'm not doing
anything well it looks to me like you
are
[Music]
[Laughter]